what did he say that farmers wouldn't
have a leather briefcase does he want me
to make it look like a toolbox instead
no just make the outside metal and
remove the Insignia have the Phoenix on
the loading screen huh those are
actually good notes I thought so too
might be easier to waterproof and
definitely will be easier to conceal
with other metal objects than making a
farmer seem like a lawyer I think we
could get him to sign off on production
if he could it in Action a field test to
prove the usage exactly in the
simulation room or in the field
simulation is safer it's easier to
control the variables to get the desired
outcome set it
up what's the point of this mobile
medical support nanotechnology deployed
to do field triage exactly we equi the
warhound with one of these Deployable
medical support stations they drop the
station into a combat area and the
nanotech goes to work assessing the
status of your operator in the field
they can cauterize wounds administer
small doses of adrenaline or combat
cocktails deploy expanding foam to stem
bleeding and you've built the Nanobots
for this they are still theoretical but
the deployment mechanism is real we have
the ones that deliver the expanding foam
but they are onetime use and they can't
fly back to the fly trap and be picked
up by the warhound fly trap that's what
Alex has been calling the device that
houses the nanotech clever thank you
this is promising let me know when the
traps are fully
operational mobile shade servers have
been delivered to all rural Outpost and
the next shipment is due to roll off the
assembly line next month they will be
installed at Central hubs in all major
metropolitan areas you don't think
that's Overkill it's a Band-Aid you can
never have enough Band-Aids in a war
zone are you expecting us to be at War
soon I expect that Nat wouldn't be
ordering so many War hounds if she
didn't need them and if she's getting
ready for war we should be too
understood your AI just got one of my
agents killed hello Cal nice to hear
your voice how is New York Alex what
happened one of my agents broke into a
pharmacy to get painkillers and bandages
for a gunshot wound and your AI marked
her Rogue killed her turret and left her
defenseless I'm sorry to hear that she
should have used the key I thought your
AI was supposed to be smart my AI is
smart Isaac leaves much to be desired I
can't have my agents left defenseless
because Isaac is a Boy Scout we have a
work around then do it if I allow your
agents to have full access to the system
even if they go Rogue you know what this
means right yes do you also want me to
activate stage one of the hunter
protocol that's the fail safe stage one
only allows you to activate individuals
on a Case by case basis if you want them
all online we have to move to stage
three I remember individual Regional
National that's correct just do it this
was never supposed to happen it wasn't
but I'm glad we're ready just in case
you weren't ready this is a show
this this is food poisoning just stay
hydrated and pray this whole thing blows
over in a couple of days don't need the
sales pitch right now Alex I need your
Tech to do its job okay it's
done Rogue agents now have access to
their Tech and if one of them becomes a
problem you can activate a hunter to
dispatch of said problem thank you
Claire I'm sorry yelled this is just
this was not where I had planned to be
when this all went down no one expects
to be at Ground Zero but once you're
there you either adapt or die lucky for
you you've got an army to get through
before you die that's not as comforting
as you think Claire if you need anything
else will be in the bunker at least
those systems are working fine thank
birdie for the Power Solutions the
defense systems are really impressive
now that the power is
stable the Holograms are not working as
intended we need a more stable power
source Cal says he's working on it I
really hope that doesn't mean what I
think it means you knew that we would
need to bring in additional funding and
Consultants but not him I can't work
with him I know but if you want to get
the new system into production we need
their help Cal promised you can work
directly with birdie you won't have to
see Vic at
all I can work with birdie other than
the power supply any other red flags
from the field test concerned the AI
might be too sensitive and quick to
marking the user off Mission and
removing access to the tech is there an
easy win there yeah we mark them off
Mission but don't kill their access we
alert other users to a Potential Threat
but in case the AI is just being touchy
we allow the user to still have access
to their Tech H Visual and auditory
alert yeah we'll change their UI to red
and Isaac will detect the status change
and alert surrounding users we'll suck
for people who are color blind or in
certain lighting conditions but the
voice backup should alleviate that issue
a bit it's not perfect but it's better
than killing someone's Tech in the
middle of a firefight because you
accidentally shot a friendly or broke a
door lock to get to cover Isaac can be a
little dactic in his morality this is
why I prefer
Anna thank you for organizing the
testing facility and granting access to
birdie she really does have a brilliant
mind for this kind of work happy to be
of service I'm honestly surprised how
Hands-On you are with this project when
only a handful of people have the
clearance to support it you have to hold
more hands my hope is to make that a
little easier for you oh I'm working on
a new program that will completely
automate the simulation and training for
your operatives and make it easier for
birdie to do her work independently
anything you can do to make this project
go smoother with fewer hands on deck the
better and whenever you finish those
upgrades Nat is paying for I would be
happy to inherit any of her old and
surplus
toys how did it go terrible they hated
my idea oh don't worry that's not just
you they hate all ideas except their own
birdie birdie doesn't count she's like
some kind of savant something and
honestly I think she's just so birdie
that it's easier to get out of her way
and let her do whatever crazy ass thing
is in her head it's not fair no it's not
fair but a lot of things aren't Fair
it's a solid idea but I need their money
to build the Prototype what's the pitch
terrestrial
firebomb why original concept to deploy
into forest fires to do control burn so
that we don't have to use a smoke jumper
that's a good idea but too philanthropic
for this Bunch find a combat application
and maybe I gave them a combat
application but they said it was too War
crimey they've got automated drones how
is this any more war crimey than the
they already have in development it
was their idea so of course it's beyond
reproach I hate rich
people trust me Cal will buy
if we use Isaac what's the problem with
Anna he's a good old boy you saw how the
subjects responded to the Prototype
openly hostile towards having the female
AI tell them what to do yeah I remember
it's ridiculous and sexist and utterly
disgusting it is but we know that and if
we want to keep funding the development
of the tech we need to secure this
contract and Isaac Isaac will secure the
deal you only like him because he's you
and you prefer Anna cuz she's
you I want you to equip all our
personnel with this new artiz tech you
mean the operatives in the field no I
want you to equip all our Personnel you
don't think that's an invasion of
privacy I don't know what you're talking
about the new Isaac Tech is supposed to
be able to access and data mine all
surveillance equipment and recording
devices it comes into contact with yes
our Personnel are often in civilian
spaces like restaurants and Banks and
theaters if they're wearing this Tech
anyone they come into contact with will
have their uploaded to Isaac system if
it actually does what they promise
exactly you don't believe the tech works
as intended I don't believe and trust in
the word of a Salesman who barely
graduated I don't want to trust in a
belief I want to see test results that
confirm if it's snake oil they're
selling if it's I want to know
will you cancel the contract if we find
the tech doesn't work of course not if I
don't spend my budget I lose my budget
got to keep the wheels of Congress
greased and ready to fund the new future
of warfare you mean security yes
security if we have this Teck it's only
a matter of time before enemies do
honestly I hope it's otherwise
all our secrets will be for sale to the
highest bidder and the government's
pockets are not that
deep sir I really think we should take a
closer look at Amherst I've already
given local Leos a heads up they've
investigated and cleared him I'm looking
at his online activity do you have a
warrant to monitor him no how do you
have access to his online activity are
you hacking him no of course not it's
the Isaac servers fruit from the poison
tree since when do you care where the
fruit comes from Waller is trying to
crack down on privacy protections
getting ready for re-elections and cyber
security is a Hot Topic so we are just
supposed to ignore an active threat for
politics we are supposed to serve at the
pleasure of the president if you want to
continue to serve this President we need
to follow his lead understood sir I will
try to find some non-poisonous fruit on
Amhurst